welcome to the hugging face spaces
spotlight show it's the show where we
show off interesting examples from the
hug and face community i'm your host
nate today we've got a great lineup
we're going to take a look at anime gand
b2 for face stylization then we'll look
at dolly mini for text image generation
and then we'll end by looking at the
data measurements tool which lets you
investigate and analyze data sets let's
get started
okay so this is anime gan v2 by ak
it basically takes in a picture of
somebody's face and tries to make them
look like an anime character so uh
here's bill gates here's elon musk uh he
looks looking good
uh let's try queen b
great um
yeah you know this one got really
popular on twitter because people like
to use their own faces let's see what uh
let's see what snoop dogg's would look
like
um it looks good i think i think if this
if his face was aligned more straight in
the image it probably would have done
better
here's an example of julian which is my
boss uh but it's cropped too far out so
it looks like it's not it looks like
it's not doing as well
so let's let's not do julian dirty let's
try to let's try to crop his face a
little bit closer and see how that does
and look at that awesome
he does seem to have two different
colored eyes there but
we're gonna go with it
[Music]
all right this is the next one this is
dolly mini which is by borisdema at all
this was posted to the flax jacks
community event
and basically takes in a sentence in
this case we're going to use new york
city at night and then it'll try to
generate pictures of that
using machine learning so
let's see a few moments later all right
so here we see some ai generated
pictures of new york city at night it
kind of looks like new york city and my
nightmares um
but it's interesting nonetheless let's
try another one um hmm
what should we do
let's uh let's see what mark
zuckerberg's final form looks like
this is a good example because
the model only knows what it's been
trained on so if it doesn't know
anything about mark zuckerberg it's
probably not gonna do a very good job
but maybe it'll know something about
mark in general
we don't know um but let's see what that
looks like two seconds later okay so
this is mark zuckerberg's final form i
think some of these are pretty spooky
that one on the top right looks kind of
like
a spaceman
all of them seem to have gotten
a male
male person's face so uh i'd say didn't
do too bad of a job
let's do one more let's see what techno
album cover art would look like
three hours later can you move it along
i'm all out of time
all right uh so this is some techno
techno album cover art uh
and this looks pretty good i really like
that one in the middle
um
wow so it did a pretty good job
uh great so that's dolly mini
let's take a look now at the data
measurements tool the data measurements
tool was created by a few people here at
hugging face meg yaseen and sasha
so let's take a look it basically lets
you choose uh some different data sets
that they pre-computed some statistics
for uh here we're going to take a look
at squad which is for question answering
squad has been pretty widely used um
especially in the past
here you can see you know some different
things about the data set the data set
description some examples from it uh
some of the most common words here you
can also take a look at the
lengths of the different pieces of text
so
this is sort of the
the relative frequency of the different
text lengths in the data set
here we can see kind of like the
shortest shortest uh length texts all
right so i thought this one was
interesting so here's a list of the
duplicated terms in the data set this is
a training set by the way uh one of them
is i couldn't come up with another
question but i need to fill this space
because i can't submit the hit and that
was duplicated five times so you really
want to make sure you look at your data
sets when you're training before you're
training on something
so you don't end up training on
something like that another one is dd
right so that's that's that's uh dd
comes up three times in the in the
training data set
so thanks for watching the hug and face
faces spotlight show if you like this
video consider giving a like and
subscribe to our youtube channel for
more content like this
you can also connect to over 3000 other
people interested in machine learning by
joining our discord server thanks for
watching until next time bye
[Music]
you